hello everyone we are pleased to have
you join us for cardinal health lab
exchange welcome to today's live
broadcast foundations for lean and judy
auric of lab roots and i'll be your
moderator for today's webinar we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by cardinal health Cardinal
Health is a fortune 22 company that
improves the cost effectiveness of
healthcare as the business behind
healthcare cardinal health helps
pharmacies hospitals ambulatory surgery
centers clinical laboratories and
physician offices focus on patient care
while reducing costs enhancing
efficiency and improving quality
Cardinal Health employs more than 34,000
people worldwide for more information
please visit www com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Chris
dillinger chris is the director of
operational excellence for Cardinal
Health in this rural chris has
responsibilities and governance for
enterprise operational excellence and
lean leadership development programs for
cardinal health spending 35,000
employees and multiple continents chris
is a certified Lean Six Sigma master
black belt he has 25 years of healthcare
industry experience including leadership
positions in the areas of laboratory
corporate health and operational
excellence Chris serves as a coach for
the ohio state university Fisher College
of Business mboe program and the academy
for excellence in health
I will now turn it over to Chris
Dillinger for his presentation all right
well good morning and afternoon everyone
welcome on today's webcast I would like
to share some guiding principles of lean
with you and we're going to talk about
the key elements of a lean management
system specifically leader standard work
lean and the manager in the management
system are powerful catalyst for
operational and cultural transformation
the first let's ground herself on the
current landscape of health care it's
from our viewpoint formed from many
different points of access around the
business of health care that the health
care model today is really unsustainable
so first we have aging seniors so the
population is getting older about 10,000
people every day become Medicare
eligible we also are dealing with more
and more chronic illnesses 30 for
example thirty percent of american
adults are considered to be obese which
is double the percentage in the past
three decades and approximately 32
million additional people are gaining
access to care so we are faced with the
challenges in health care of more people
sicker people and less money to take
care of them and oh by the way there's
still the existing demand for better
care and outcomes with higher consumer
satisfaction so hospitals is well facing
those challenges also have to deal with
declining reimbursement rates as this
graph shows that over time the amount of
money being available for payment is is
reducing so healthcare providers are
facing enormous are facing enormous
pressures and new federal mandates will
require hospitals and other health
your providers to run more efficiently
and to improve patient outcomes also
more and more people with more and more
people entering the health care system
and reimbursement with the reimbursement
rates defining so providers are looking
for new ways to reduce waste and take
costs out of the system as well as
finding new ways to innovate and deliver
their valued services within Atlanta
cific Lee we have some additional
challenges that we are facing including
increased competition technology
advances labor shortages care is being
delivered closer to home and as well as
traditional many of the traditional lab
services being become commoditized so as
we as I mentioned earlier that lean
itself is a powerful catalyst to help
drive operational and cultural
transformations that they're going to
help either hospitals or independent
labs survive in this new world so in
Cardinal Health we went on our own lean
journey and and I don't want to get too
deep into this but I do want to share a
little bit of the perspective and the
challenges that we faced going through
our concept to reality so back in
2004-2005 a cardinal health started what
we call operational excellence and
originally our focus was very much on
just general process improvement quality
and out focusing on the quality and the
operations part of our business and it
was to drive costs out of the system and
at the time we just we had a significant
rush to the classroom we brought it
hundreds and thousands of sponsors and
trained some black belts and Kaizen
leaders to go after the work and at the
time it was very much tool driven but
but over the the early years we saw me
to shift from this tool base to more of
a value stream thinking and then as we
evolved even further we started to shift
towards more of a value creation type of
a model operational excellence became
embedded in her talent review process of
overtime as well so people who lift
through the black belt program they were
viewed as potentially the next leaders
of the organization in on an annual
basis and the talent review process the
the black belts were looked at as who
who is who is ready to move on into a
new leadership role we also started to
shift some of our focus from just our
internal operations and improving it but
also we started to work with some of our
customers and doing customer trials just
to see where we could start aligning
that value streaming and connect the
bigger pieces and said that just being
internally focused we also started to
shift from our operational elements to
some of our office functions finance ite
Human Resources things like that in over
the last handful of years there's been a
more pronounced intention to make
operational excellence and mean
specifically an enterprise capability
how do we develop the perfect processes
and and we generated these things called
lean roadmaps lean roadmap to success
where we would evaluate all of our
operations on the journey that they're
taking to becoming more of a lean
enterprise and then in the last couple
years we've introduced a main leader
program so so now we're not talking
about full-time resources such as black
belts doing this work but we started
talking with some of our senior senior
leaders and targeting those people to
understand what it means to lead in a
lean environment and leader standard
work is a big part of that and I'll
touch on those and later slides and then
in the last year we've developed two new
programs that again help us to extend
that value stream not just to working on
our own operations but we work with the
power suppliers and they also work with
our customers to get that full value
stream view the two additional offers
that we
implementing that lately is the academy
for excellence in health care as well as
performance improvement improvement
consulting directly targeted at
opportunities to further the lean
movement if you will in hospitals and
customers faces so the business impact
that we've seen at cardinal health is to
give you a flavor of as you go down this
if you would decide to go down this road
of of lean in your organization's that
some of the impact that you may expect
to see for example we saw a fifty-five
percent reduction in our safety
incidents we saw improved quality on our
DPM sanford defects per million
opportunity so we saw our quality
indicators go up we saw our employee
engagement scores go up by twenty
percent as well as improving
productivity by nineteen percent so we
as you can see by the numbers we had
some significant increases and
improvement around our performance and
safety quality employed voice of the
employee as well as our productivity
rate so its meaning a little trying to
eat a little more specific now to the
lab if I were to ask what is the mission
of your laboratory I would expect that I
may hear some responses like you're here
to serve your patients physicians
clients you want to deliver high-quality
results so you want innovative new
minima innovative opportunities and
services to deliver as well as doing
research and ultimately how do we
deliver health care in a more
cost-effective manner so these are some
of the typical responses because those
are the things that we see as being
important to your patients they're
important to your customers such as you
know your physician clients and also the
community itself those are the things
that they would expect from the
laboratory but the question that
needs to be answered is but are your
resources whether that's labor or
capital or space I'm really being used
to fulfill these missions or they over
commit it to a non-value-added producing
activity so we've thinking on the
previous slide we talked about some of
those things are important to your
patients for example and I hope that you
would agree that those things just don't
magically happen that there are
processes involves and connections that
have to be made handoffs and
communication that's all important for
it to work to it for it to work well but
these processes the deliberate value
they can be broken down into steps or
activities and these activities either
generate value or they do not so in
thinking it's about trying to understand
what value is and to focus on key
processes so that we continue so that we
can continually improve and increase the
value being generated from that process
much of our laboratories and our
organizations and the health care
continuum itself is very function is
very functional oriented it's very
siloed approach that we have our
phlebotomist and we have our specimen
processors and we have our technologists
and we have our pathologists and we have
the physicians all these people operate
in the mental state independently but
somewhat independently of one another
within their within their silos but to a
comp in in the meanwhile the value
that's being driven into the patient
what's important what is really
important to me an end user in customer
the patient it is many times it's
happening in the background as we
optimize these silos that we work in so
the question is is how do we move the
focus of managing and optimizing these
separate silos or separate technologies
and vertical departments to how do we
optimize the flow of products or
services that flow more horizontal
stop so so here it's really just a
change of the focus instead of having
the value flowing across the background
that's how do you bring it up front and
work at what we would consider to be the
value stream level and how do we keep
value moving across those silos knowing
that they still exist and more than
likely will exist in the future as well
so ultimately you know that lean
thinking is how how do we find ways to
maximize customer value while minimizing
the waste so if you're unfamiliar with
lean guiding principles wanted to make
that objective today and at least share
you know what lean guiding principles
are and the five those five key elements
that we focus on particularly hear it at
cardinal health so the first one is
creating value for the customer and at
the end of the day the person who
determines and defines value is going to
be the customer the patient that that
end user perhaps it's the physician and
do we really know what our customers
want or do we have models built where we
assume what they want or we tell them
what they want as opposed to really
understanding what's important to them
and what they value the second lien
guiding principle is aligning to the
value stream so how do we create the
eyes for seeing waste and work to
eliminate activities that do not add
value to the customer just like the
slides before when I talked about that
horizontal view or that value stream so
an example could be you know let's use a
pap smear test you know they in
traditional LabVIEW that maybe you
looked at how do we perform this pap
smear and generate these you know these
these results in the most efficient and
optimal way for the for the
laboratory as opposed to if you take a
value stream approach you may be looking
at the entire patient experience from
the time that they're making an
appointment all the way to the time that
they're receiving the results so it's
not just a focus on the testing
component itself but but the whole
experience of that that gynecological
visit for example that is looking at a
value stream because how how and when a
specimen is collected is going to
ultimately impact how and how its tested
as well as you know the quality of the
results on me and so how do we look
upstream and downstream from the testing
activity so sorry about that the fourth
guiding principle of Arizona misread the
third guiding principle of lean is going
to be to create flow and customer driven
pool catch phrase here that I like to
use is batching is bad so how do we keep
whatever value exists in that process
whether that's a service or information
how do we keep it moving forward and
every time we stop wastin value value is
ultimately destroyed and batching is a
it's a big destroyer of value if you
will it creates inefficiencies so for
example an example in lab would be
phlebotomy morning drawls you know the
phlebotomist collectible a specimen send
it to the lab collect another specimen
send it to the lab particularly if
you're in an area like an ICU versus do
I collect ten specimens and batch them
and then send them all down to the lab
at the same time because from the time
that the first bussmann is collected
until the tenth specimens collected
there's a significant amount of time
that goes by and waiting which which can
delay results so anyway that the catch
phrase here in lean is going to be that
batching is
at the fourth point in lean and the
guiding principle is going to be seeking
perfection so how do we seek perfection
how do we speed up the process or the
cycle of continuous improvement how do
we learn to fail fast as opposed to you
know not really understanding what root
cause problem solving is and that we
make a mistake we blame a person instead
of the process and just to have that
error reaper over and over and over
again because we haven't taken the time
to really seek the perfection understand
root cause blaine in the process and
figure out a way to fix it and solve it
on a long-term permanent basis and last
in the last one is respected every
individual so we believe that in in lean
when you were working on cleaning those
process improvement you need the people
who do the work to be the ones who help
find countermeasures and solutions to
the problems that exist we believe that
they have more valuable information and
the managers because they live it and
breathe it every day and we want to make
sure that our workforce understands you
know that that they are empowered to
make the necessary changes to the work
itself so it's they they in fact are the
subject matter experts of the work so
jumping from you know the lean guiding
principles to now understanding how it
fits into a larger context or a larger
lean management system and one of the
key important elements of a lean
management system is something called
leader standard work so why is it
important so leader standard work is the
engine of a lean management system that
allows leaders to focus on not just the
results that they get the monthly you
know business reports that they have
accountability for the
also the processes themselves so how do
they focus on the process and seek that
perfection and continuously improve
everyday by through engaging the
employees so leader standard work is is
real important so just as you might have
standard work or standard procedures for
the frontline employees who are
performing testing in the lab or
performing any type of activity in those
procedures give them clear expectations
we need the same for our leaders so if
you're a lab supervisor or a manager
it's important that you have a routine
and standard work in your day-to-day
activities as well leave your Santa work
has benefits around making this
management system of lean process
dependent not person appendant so as you
have leaders come and go within your
organization or get promoted into new
roles we want to make sure that the
business still is able to flow and the
processes and quality of results are
dependent upon that particular
individual as a leader but Moritz we
have a system in place that allows
quality to happen and improve over over
time it takes us from you know this
environment of firefighting and dealing
with the problem of today but how how do
we carve out certain percentage of the
time and not a hundred percent of your
time but how do you carve out ten
percent of your day or twenty percent of
your day every day to really think about
how how do we stabilize our processes on
a long-term basis identify root cause as
opposed to just dealing with what comes
across your desk in that particular
moment so why do we want to use it so
some of the benefits I just talked about
but it really is that structured list of
you know daily daily weekly monthly
tasks and activities that the leaders
want to go through to make sure that the
operation is functioning
well and delivering against those lean
principles that we had talked about a
little bit earlier by cream leader
leader standard work is well in the lab
you're generating that collaboration and
opportunities exist not just within the
laboratory itself but even across the
hospital again as an example across
hospital departments so for example what
is the cadence or the routine in which
that leader communicates with the
emergency department is it once a month
of the meeting is it never what about
every shift you know is are there
possibilities where you could have lab
techs or supervisors be speaking
directly with you know somebody in the
emergency department every every shift
about what's going on what instruments
are up and what was our down you know
what does the volume looking like in the
ED your have the ability to address
problems as they arrive of labeling
errors that come up and how do we root
cause that and prevent those errors from
happening the next shift or the next day
so a leader standard work are
standardized to actions and messages you
know the behaviors that the leaders can
execute against to deliver the business
results that are needed so as I
mentioned before this leader standard
work component really part of a larger
lean operating system or learning
management system in we want to make
sure that now conveyed a message along
as webcast that that mean is much more
than just a set of tools that drive out
waste it really is part of a bigger
system a bigger operating system or lean
management system and leader standard
work is one I chose to focus on today as
being one of those key elements to that
but some of the other elements are true
north and true north is representing in
the strategy itself so what is the
overall guiding direction of the
organization and management system also
employee development as part of the lean
management system we want to make sure
that the employees are being respected
we want to make sure that they have
personal development on an ongoing basis
and this does it just at the annual
performance review when when you sit
down and have a talk but it's more of on
a daily basis how do we continue to
develop and improve our people and give
them opportunities to grow in Excel
another component to a lean management
system is going to be accountability
processes so once once the manager or
leader has established you know what are
the expectations is what what where the
accountability processes around making
sure that those assignments task
activities that get carried out for
example there's also visual management
so how do we educate and inform the
people who are doing the work how we're
performing at any given moment so is it
does it do us much good at the end of a
month to run a cycle time report and say
hey the look that the specimen
turnaround time for a potassium was 18
minutes and you find that out at the end
of the month as opposed to what I would
like to know where I'm performing on a
daily basis or even an hourly basis for
that matter collecting ed ed turnaround
time on a complete blood count at the
end of the month is saying that it is
out of out of expectation and out of
specification it's difficult to root
cause problem solve that and you can get
down to what the real problems are when
that data is you know now anywhere from
you know one or two days to 40 days old
so visual management system and how we
collect and display information so that
everybody understands the work that
needs to be done and current performance
bubbles then there's standard work
a lean management system is going to
have the built-in standard work for the
for the part of the procedures
themselves and the weren't getting done
for the employees performing that but
then lastly is the leader standard work
part and how do we focus on the
activities of you know the leader so
what is leader standard work again we
talked talked about it quite a bit but
it really is the routines the leader
routines that are necessary to sustain
that lean management system and the
frequency in which they happen so that
we can count on on a daily basis I'm
going to do ABC and D on a weekly basis
I'm going to do the next three things as
opposed to well some days I do it some
days I don't you know can the people who
report to me really count on clear
communications and clear expectations
from me so leader standard work will
define those actions and behaviors that
are expected of the leader and how the
leader is going to interact and engage
with the frontline staff you know what
is that cadence and what is that mode of
communication and that that would
include these visual management pieces
that I just talked about before but all
along there's a focus on the process and
the value stream of course results are
important but how do we focus on the
process and the value stream that
generates any of the value for the
patient or the physician or the customer
as opposed to you know how do we just be
internally focused on our silo and what
makes us um optimal as opposed to
optimizing that by stream and as well as
we want to make sure as leaders that we
first seek the blame the process and not
the people
alright so what are the elements of
leader standard work so there are six
different elements that I'll describe in
a little bit more detail but all of them
are important to generating the desired
results that you would want in a lean
type of culture or lean environment so
those those elements are number one
daily teen reflections or meetings so an
example example would be do I have shift
meetings or cuddles on first shift or I
gather all the texts in that particular
work area or even across the entire lap
pull them together for a quick
five-minute conversation to under to set
expectations set the pace for the day
recognize them you know big give
employee recognition for job well done
talk about you know any meetings that we
have scheduled coming up that day that
may take texts off the bench or that's
going to create conflicts around lunch
schedules and things like that we have
any special instrumentation issues that
that we need to make sure that
everybody's informed about in that
particular day that that the hematology
instrument is going to have some
preventive maintenance done on it
between 10am and 11am and make sure
everybody's aware of that and what are
the backup procedures or help that might
be needed as we can perhaps we need to
shift some labor resources around during
that time period so daily teen
reflections in the laboratory is a great
way to improve communications and
understanding it's also in those
meetings is also a great opportunity to
identify you know problems and how do we
start soliciting suggestions on how how
those problems came about and what are
the root causes to make to make them go
away
to daily reflection that is a simple
element that you could apply and execute
in the laboratory pretty quickly if
you're if you're not already doing that
again that can be the shift level and it
can even spin outside the department as
I mentioned earlier for example with Ed
or ICU labor and delivery things like
that second key element to leader
standard work our inbox so gimbal walks
is a lean turning Gimba refers to the
place where the action happens the place
where the work is done so for example
sitting in a conference room or sitting
in your office really doesn't give you a
full appreciation for the work that gets
that needs to be done as well as the
problems that may exist in the
opportunities that makes is to improve
that process so you might be surprised
as a leader or attack if you just took a
moment as difficult as it may be to step
back on take a breath if you will and
observe so if you would just have the
opportunity that may be stand back and
observe in microbiology how a specimen
enters the lab how it gets processed how
the person needs to interact with the
computer to get the information into the
system where are the supplies a where
those supplies at that they need to
plate that particular culture specimen
and if you just sit and observe and
think boy that's really crazy you know
Susie has to plate this media you know
50 times a day because that's the volume
of this type of culture and the and one
of the tools that she needs to do that
is you know 15 feet away and she has to
walk how do we move the materials and
the supply needed to perform the work
closer to where the work happens and
many times we may just read a procedure
manual and or or if you're
right the procedure nan Yun Seong he
just do steps one two three four and
five seems pretty simple but when you
observe it in action and watch it live
and you see you know the barriers that
exist the distance that people have to
travel the interruptions that happen I
have to walk around the end of this
table you start to identify you know
that maybe there's opportunities to
improve the work and the way it's
designed the gimbal walks is not it's
not intended to be a place and once
again to point fingers or blame and and
and be observing Suzie doing the work
and say boy you know Suzie why don't you
do this or why don't you do that try
this or try that it really is a place
where you can observe the work and then
engage the employees for their input on
how to improve the work at another time
a third key element in leader standard
work is having an immediate response to
the abnormalities in the process so how
do we recognize opportunities how do we
deal with those in a more expedient
manner instead of waiting for a report
to be generated out of the lis or the
computer system you know a month later
how do we how do we recognize
abnormalities in the process immediately
and take action upon those in a more
expedient manner so for example a lean
tool even though trying to avoid tools a
little bit you know the common lean to
land foundation of means is going to be
5 s so 5s is going to be you know a
methodology or a system that helps us
organize the work area and create a
safer more organized workspace that
allows value to flow and instead of
being impeded and it also helps us to
identify abnormalities in the process
pretty readily so if you picture you
know a shadow board
um you know a board where your tools are
kept if you will and you know the 100 ml
pipette is missing where it's easy to
identify that pipette is not where it's
supposed to be and that will cause the
problem in the workflow going forward
and how do we easily recognize that and
deal with it and fix that abnormality
immediately a fourth key component to
leader leader standard work is going to
be visual management so visual
management talked about that a little
bit before so I'm not going to go too
much further in detail on that but if
you think about in the laboratory there
there's opportunities to help us
identify whether the process is working
or not working so for example you know
could we put something in place that's
that's visual that once we get to a
build up of five slide racks that we
take action instead of waiting for 10
that you set some things in control that
a once we get the five we're starting to
back up we need to reallocate resources
we need to take some type of action so
where are the visual ways that can help
us identify these abnormalities in the
process but also help us to identify you
know what's normal in that the process
is performing to expectations sometimes
it's simple as a piece of masking tape
on a wall you know that when we we put
our supplies in a certain area and we
stack them on top of one another maybe
it maybe it's cubes of saline and a
blood bank for example and we typically
would need to have you know three of
these on hand and you put a piece of
masking tape across the wall that's
whenever you get below a certain point
it's a trigger for you to take some
actions such as reordering blood bank
saline but you don't have to always go
and count every single item or supply
but instead just have so many visual
management tools in place that anyone
can easily identify abnormal situation
from you know the normal flow and that
the process and work is happening away
expected as well as those accountability
things that I talked about before of the
metrics of success how do we post the
the metrics that we measure on a daily
weekly monthly basis so that people
understand where we're at whether that's
turnaround times or whether that's
quality indicators or even cost for that
matter you know what it was our cost per
test and visit everybody in the
laboratory understand what the cost is
what the drivers are and in their role
in that so visual management is a huge
component of lean in particular leader
standard work as well the fifth fifth
element that I want to talk about is
employee coaching so one of the Lean
principles that I've mentioned before
being the respect every individual and
is it is you could argue that it is
disrespectful to an employee to waste
their time and effort so we want to
respect all of our employees and as a
leader and part of the leader standard
work component of how how do we coach
and inform and educate communicate with
our employees on a routine basis we're
talking we're not talking about the
annual performance review when I sit
down and talk to Suzie about her
particular performance across the year
you know that's enough that has its play
time in place but employee coaching it's
more of that what is the day to day
weekly week by week interaction with an
employee that you can help them develop
personally
on a more frequent basis and also to
hear from them you know what they
struggle with on a day-to-day basis what
gets in the way of been doing a good job
you know I want to believe and I think
mostly in practitioners or who are going
to you believe that everybody comes to
work to do a good job but there are
things that happen there's processes and
barriers that prevent us from doing a
good job I didn't come here today you
know to work to mess up this specimen or
mislabel something but what what systems
do we have in place that help support me
as an employee and can coach me through
it to help set me up for success as
opposed to setting me up for failure and
the last element of leader standard work
that I want to talk about is the
strategy development and all of you know
all the activities of the lab hopefully
roll up to some type of strategic
initiative or some type of a strategic
plan within the lab because it's a lot
easier to get people to understand how
it all fits together if in fact there it
there is a strategy and a strategy in
place that everybody can be you know
pulling the ropes in the same direction
if you will so for example um I'll go
back to pap smears again you know
specific example a lab that I've worked
at you know pap smear turnaround time
was 21 days and you know physician
offices work leaving and you still have
the business so apparently you know
there's no problem right people are
complaining there's no problem as
opposed to you know having a strategy
that you know every female who has this
test done has a level of anxiety about
that test and and we want to be on
patient centric so our strategy is going
to be we want to be paid
centric around pap smear testing and
what does that mean they sure as heck
doesn't mean that we're going to have a
21 day turnaround time while that person
is waiting for the results that come
back for 3 weeks when you know that that
test could be performed quite honestly
really same day so what is the strategy
of the lab and you know what are the
values of the laboratory that we can get
everybody pulling towards that will
reflect the type of care that we really
want to deliver to the community so my
last slide is I wanted to highlight some
specific examples of you know waste that
exists within a laboratory in case
you're you know in case you are new to
the saline thing and understanding you
know what is it and what is this waste
and and that you're talking about so we
use an acronym a common acronym we uses
something called Tim trim wood and it
stands for transportation resources
inventory motion waiting over production
over processing and and defects so
examples of transportation waste that
exist within the lab that you'll have
maybe some new eyes to recognize is
moving specimens from place to place so
if you go back to the batching is bad
how often in a lab do we receive a
specimen in it might come in on the
courier and a big bag with 25 other
specimens it sits on the counter then we
perform some work activity to it to get
it you know maybe registered into the
laboratory information system and then
we just move it and put it in a big rack
and it sits there in that rack and then
we move it to another place and then we
move it to another place so all that
moving of specimens and moving supplies
around doesn't add any value to the
patient and it doesn't have any value to
the results if anything
runs the risk of deteriorating the
results that are going to be produced
from that particular specimen so
transportation waste is a common thing
that we would look for is what is what
is the movement of specimens and
supplies and what is the transportation
process moving it from you know an
inpatient floor the EDR from an
outpatient clinic into the laboratory
itself the second one on our is
resources and this work this one is
primarily focused around the employees
then we fully utilize our employees in
the most effective way we have
intelligent people with intelligent
ideas and we really utilize them in the
best way or do we have a top-down driven
command and control type of an
environment that this is how it's going
to be done because I said so because I
was a lab tech 15 years ago as opposed
to are we engaging our employees and
utilizing them so they're their fullest
potential is potential all right
inventory so supplies the reagents forms
that we have your email that cumulates
in your computer system all of those are
examples of inventory my experience in
lab we tend to have some bad affording
examples of you know I ran out of medium
gloves one day and that's never going to
happen to me again so the next shipment
of gloves that come in I'm going to
spike the box of those gloves and I'm
going to tuck it away in this little
drawer so that I know where it's at so
if we ever start to run low on gloves
again that I have my gloves available to
me so sharing the story lines working in
the lab one day in fact we did run out
of gloves and the lab manager came out
upset said open up all drawers all
lockers all cabinets and let's see what
we have and and we found 38 boxes of
gloves that particular day
um just from all the hoarding behavior
that was going on within the lab but it
was a learned behavior you know it was
something that our processes didn't
support we didn't have a good inventory
systems in place that assured us that we
had the supplies that we needed when we
needed though so it it's exacerbated and
some of those negative behaviors if you
love motion is another form of waste
that we would look for in and lean in a
laboratory and that's running around
looking for those supplies looking for
specimens that we can't find you know
where's the centrifuge located i need to
centrifuge the specimens that are going
to people you know the specimens are
going to be used for this particular
test but yet the centrifuges three
aisles away for from the actual testing
area so what is the physical layout of
the space how do we how do we make
specimens flow in a more linear or a
u-shaped fashion as opposed to more that
crisscross that a specimen goes from one
area around three benches to somebody
else and then they do their thing with
it and then they take it across two more
benches and then it goes to the back
hallway before it ends up back up front
again into a refrigerated area so what
what is the physical layout and design
of the lab because it makes sense for
the flow of an individual specimen of
particularly those specimens that we
share such as body fluids and
microbiology specimens perhaps the next
formal waste is waiting I think I talked
about that quite a bit my example was
the racks where we where we have
specimens and we batch them and we just
collect them before we put them on and
the analyzer and the analyzer maybe in a
random access where you can immediately
put things on but yet yet we stuck them
in you know racks of 20 or 30 before we
perform the task I recognize it
sometimes there are some QC
considerations there that go into play
but in general we want to be looking at
how do we reduce the amount of waiting
that a specimen sits before before we
can add the value to that that specimen
and generate the results over production
is we tend to make more than is
necessary so for example I have on here
expired reagents that we use a hundred
ml of a particular reagent every week
but you know while I'm at it I'm going
to go ahead and make up a half a gallon
of it just so I don't have to do it
again and all we do is produce more than
we need just to throw it away so we've
used more than is necessary and it just
gets pitched or outdated forms you know
what we have an outreach lab business
and we get a hundred specimens a day a
hundred specimens a month from this
particular doctor's office but you know
what I can I can get a really good deal
on printing costs if I order them by the
thousand so I'm going to order a
thousand of them instead of ordering the
hundred that I need and then that's
going to take up space the most
laboratories don't have so we tend to
over produce and make more forms and
reagents or in pathology we make extra
slides heck while I'm cutting this
tissue i want to make four slides
instead of the two that were actually
needed and requested the next one is
over processing over processing is where
we're generating in a more value perhaps
than it's really necessary or asked for
so for example you know that we order
i'll use culture sensitivity so on a
urine during culture you know we tended
no what bugs are going to be susceptible
to what antibiotics but yet we're going
to go ahead and perform a sensitivity on
it anyway and are we you know really
just putting money down the drain by
over over processing and doing more
testing than is necessary manual
differentials you know are we are we
doing more manual differentials than are
necessary given the fact that the
instrumentation looks at many more cells
and have had the measurement systems
analyzed to make sure that they in fact
are accurate and you know are there
opportunities in that area as well and
the last thing I want to talk about our
defects those are usually pretty
self-explanatory when it comes to you
know specimen identification errors and
penalized specimens that get rejected
maybe re cuts on pathology slides you
know results are late on a turnaround
time against the turnaround time
expectation you know those are pretty
easy to defects to define and recognize
but but but a new thing that I challenge
you know those on the webcast to be
thinking about you know lean and in a
laboratory you're looking around is you
know any time that I see something
sitting around and not progressing and
value isn't flowing forward you know how
is that considered to be in our mind
defect and something that we should
investigate and look for opportunities
to improve so with that that that's
that's my fast and dirty initiation and
introduction into some of the
foundations of the Lean principles of
the five Lean principles as well as
where how lean fits into a larger
operation operational system or a lean
management system and I chose to focus
specifically on lean standard work they
you may have some you know management
people in the audience today that that
may get some value out of you know
perhaps a different way to work as a
leader as opposed to just changing the
way my staff works but how do i change
the way I work as well so at this point
I'm finished with my slides and be happy
to take some questions at this time from
the audience thank you for that
informative presentation I am thrilled
to be part of cardinal health lab
exchange before we get started on the
question and answer session i would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can't submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window will try to answer as many
questions as we can our first question
is from Mary at st. Vincent's East and
she asks what are the latest ideas in
ways to improve morning round blood
collections we collect about 120
patients every morning starting at three
clock alright well thank you Mary for
the question I'll put in a disclaimer to
you here I'll share some thoughts but I
also don't want to pretend that I that I
can solve your problem sitting in an
office somewhere and perhaps hundreds of
miles away from you so my first advice
would be to you know really just
understand the problem that you're
trying to solve in and understand what
the expectations are in the performance
expectations for it for your customers a
couple things that interest me is when
you say you collect 120 specimens every
morning there's a there's a lien term
tact here that I want to consider is
what is the pace that we need to work at
so if we understand that the lab drawl
takes you know seven minutes or whatever
the time is and I have to get 120 up and
done
what is the pace that I have to work out
so how many do I have to get done every
particular each each hour to remain on
pace to meet whatever expectations it is
so so part of me would want to say how
do I understand my pace but I need to
work at how do I make it understandable
and visible to everybody that we are on
pace and we are getting things done in a
timely manner as opposed to maybe
falling behind but more importantly the
thing that scares me a little bit is the
starting at 3am when I was working in a
lab we did something similar I think we
started at 4am and and it always
concerned me around is that really
patient centric you know if I'm if I'm
ill and in the hospital last thing I
want to be done is woke up at three
o'clock in the morning to somebody can
draw what is really a routine complete
complete blood count so I think that
there's some opportunities say how can
we improve the process that we don't
have to wake people up as early but
maybe a little more innovative would be
to consider why are we drawing routine
blood work in the morning in the first
place are there opportunities for us to
draw that routine CBC at 10pm before the
patient goes to bed and maybe is a
little less inconvenient than 3am draw
but that way we have can really assure
that the results are on the chart on the
physician does their morning rounds at
say seven seven a.m. is is there it is
there an opportunity to balance workload
and change the collection times who
earlier the next day as opposed to this
huge bolus or this huge batch of work
all happening at the same time in the
morning is how are there opportunities
to balance the workload and spread that
out over other hours of the day there
there are some analytes that the results
will change
over the e you know over over time
cortisol for example but but really this
is a routine CBC that's being drawn for
the fourth day in a row unless the
person is bleeding outwardly is it
really going to change between 10pm and
3 a.m. so i think that you know that
that's a food for thought of is there
opportunities to rebalance workload and
understand tap that concludes the
questions i would like to thank our
sponsor cardinal health for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through October of
this year you will receive an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay and we
invite you to forward that announcement
your colleagues and madness today's why
event see you next time bye